and sam this has to be subtle
subtle got it are you sure about that
so that was a lie
you don't have 10 phone numbers on this
thing
no and you've been ignoring the texts
from sam
you're alone you're 100 years old you
have no
history
he would like to take you out on a date
maybe to bingo or
a night of pinnacle pinocchio i'm really
sorry about him
why are you sorry okay
but you tangled the house into this when
you took those loans
[Applause]
forgot how hard you hit look
don't hit me again wait how old are you
106.
your new captain america
[Music]
[Applause]
my disappointment is immeasurable
and my day is ruined
[Music]
i have all of that on camera you know
that right
delete that footage let's take the
shield sam
let's take the shield and do this
ourselves we can't just run up on a man
beat him up and take it
all right get close come closer
we well which way you want to go right
you know what
fine here you happy now all right
good we're live it's a little close very
close that's what you wanted right guys
wait what are you doing are you having a
staring contest
just blink sweet jesus
we need him sam you're going back to
prison if i may
no apologism it is a masterpiece james
complete comprehensive it
captured
he's out of line but he's right
it's great
i love these
god damn jimmy this some serious gourmet
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
laughs
he said sam and bucky were here on the
same day this happened correct
you don't think they had anything to do
with them getting out do you thank you
what
so you seriously think sam and bucky
would have broken a guy like zemo out of
prison that's exactly what i think they
did they were just as desperate for
leads as we were
come on man coincidence i think not
[Applause]
[Music]
precious
[Music]
impossible it wasn't me
because that's what heroes do good talk
what's the matter the ca got you pushing
too many pencils
huh
[Music]
you just want me because you need your
muscle back without a super soldiers how
much power does the power broker really
have
more than you
so you're the power broker